vous
[Musique]
une ville
le deuxième
étranger
[Musique]
étranger [
Musique] [
Musique]
américain
nous
[Musique]
fluide
donc il y avait un moteur 40. beaucoup de 35 qui
descendaient par ici
c'est Roberts Mercado Chauffeur
puis il a parcouru un peu la route
tu as Michael Dioria
oh Gibberson ouais grand gars
tu ne voulais pas lui dire bonjour
tôt le matin, il avait besoin de
prendre son café et de traîner sur le
sol de l'appareil et il y a un
lieutenant et ensuite Morello,
tous très gentils, je ne sais pas, il y
avait un méchant dans la caserne des pompiers
[Musique]
je m'appelle Kevin Shay, je suis un pompier à la retraite de New
York, euh, je réponds le 9
à la tour sud du  le World Trade
Center où il s'est effondré
Kevin Feige
[Musique]
lorsque l'avion a heurté du
carburant qui était en feu, il est
tombé sur les voitures, les enflammant
et une fois que vous démarrez une voiture et que vous faites feu, il est
difficile de l'éteindre, alors quand nous étions
là-bas, l'un des  les gars qui étaient
en ligne avec nous signifiaient qu'ils
tenaient tous le tuyau,
il est sorti pour voir s'il y avait plus
de travail pour nous alors nous avons tenu la ligne là où il
voulait voir s'il y avait plus de travail, il
est allé dans la tour sud pour  voir s'il y
avait encore du travail quand il est sorti
le bâtiment s'effondrait je ne
savais pas que je portais mon scaphandre autonome ou mon masque et
j'opérais il nous a crié de courir
donc à ce moment-là tu n'en savais rien
le reste du bataillon non,
tout ce que je savais, c'est que mes gars étaient morts,
euh, je savais que le jour où
je me suis réveillé, soit deux jours plus tard, j'étais
conscient, je n'avais même pas vu, je
ne savais même pas que les bâtiments étaient tombés.
les médecins m'avaient dit que mon
amnésie rétrograde était causée par la fermeture de mon corps
pour me protéger,
que le traumatisme du bâtiment qui
s'effondrait, le traumatisme des blessures que
j'ai subies, le traumatisme de la perte de mes
frères était trop grand pour mon
mes circuits mentaux pour bien gérer tout cela,
donc il a préféré le laisser rester à
court terme et être effacé comme un
bélier sur un ordinateur lorsque vous l'éteignez. Salut
[Musique]
Je m'appelle Joanne Capestro et je suis une
survivante de  au 87ème étage de la
tour nord
[Musique]
je me tiens près de mon bureau avec un briquet
et une cigarette
et tout d'un coup l'avion fait boum
mais nous ne savions pas, nous ne savions vraiment pas
quel était l'impact
un impact si fort sur un saumon que
le bâtiment
s'est déroulé comme ceci, par ici, par ici,
j'ai vu ma vie devant moi, puis
c'est parti par là, puis par
là, puis par là,
puis il s'est arrêté
lorsqu'un avion m'a percuté.  je conduisais quelque chose
à mon bureau, ce fut un impact, je
le décris comme si un camion Mack venait de percuter
quelque chose,
je m'appelle Peter Bewinsky, j'étais un
employé de l'autorité portuaire de New
York, je travaillais au 69ème étage d'un World Trade Center
le matin de  le
11 septembre 2001
et cela m'a surpris
après qu'il m'ait jeté sur mon bureau, je me lève
et je me souviens quand je me suis levé du bruit
de l'acier qui craque, je me
souviens toujours de ce bruit de l'acier
dans mes oreilles et
quand je me suis levé, le  le sol roulait, il
n'était pas stable, j'avais l'impression que tout
allait
s'effondrer et que je m'envolais
et tout cela se passait en quelques secondes,
mais la seule chose dont je me souviens, c'est en
quelque sorte de me chuchoter, c'est là que
tout se termine  pour moi, c'est ici que je
meurs,
nous nous sommes tous mis à genoux
et nous allions
sortir de notre bureau
et
le deuxième bâtiment a été touché mais nous l'avons senti,
le bâtiment a commencé à trembler, j'étais comme si, [ __ ],
qu'est-ce qu'on a jamais fait  je vais
sortir d'ici
du nouvel international
alors nous avons commencé à regarder le bâtiment, j'ai
commencé à compter les fenêtres
et j'ai réalisé parce que je sais quelle est la taille de
ces fenêtres dans le bâtiment
oh c'est un gros avion ce
n'est pas juste un petit avion j'ai dit de  Mme mec, c'est
quelque chose de grand,
je m'appelle Dominic Wagnolli,
le 11 septembre 2001,
je travaillais à Manhattan en tant que
maréchal adjoint des États-Unis,
tout le monde était sur place pour essayer d'aider
à faire quelque chose, euh,
vous savez, des morceaux tombent du
bâtiment, donc à chaque fois  dans un moment, tu
t'arrêterais et tu sais, tu attendrais et
tu le verrais tomber et peu importe et tu voyais toutes
sortes de gens, je veux dire, ils
descendaient ou tu montais vers eux et ils
étaient juste un peu perdus, tu sais
choc
alors tu les fais traverser la
rue, essaie de les aider à leur dire que tu
sais assieds-toi là assieds-toi une seconde
[Musique]
tout ce que tu sentais c'était Jeff toi je dois te
dire que
je me sens comme quelqu'un si quelqu'un avait
peur, il le ferait juste  allumer une cigarette
ou s'ils ne le faisaient pas, ils étaient quelque part dans le noir
et ils ne savaient pas où ils
étaient, ils étaient comme s'ils
allumaient une allumette juste pour voir où ils
étaient. J'avais vraiment peur que le
bâtiment n'explose d'où  le
carburéacteur
et ce qui était vraiment triste,
c'était comme si
un étage avait du feu et de la fumée,
un autre étage, vous pouviez entendre une épingle tomber sur
un autre étage, vous verriez euh, vous
entendriez de la musique jouer sur
un autre étage, vous verriez du sang,
ce qui m'a vraiment dérangé le plus.  est-ce qu'il y
avait cet étage, il
y avait des gens en fauteuil roulant,
j'ai dit comment ces gens allaient descendre
[Musique]
quand j'ai apporté la chaise, tout le monde a
contribué en termes d'ouverture de la
chaise, nous avons détaché John de son
fauteuil roulant, nous
l'avons soulevé dans la chaise d'évacuation  nous
l'avons attaché là-dedans,
puis nous avons en quelque sorte développé ce système rapide,
deux personnes en haut de la chaise, deux
en bas pour la guider
lorsque nous descendions l'escalier, nous
tournions de bas en haut, le haut s'en va, c'était
tous les cinq étages et comment
Il
nous a fallu environ une heure et
demie pour descendre,
car
nous étions arrêtés en cours de route et nous
étions plus lents que la moyenne des gens
qui descendaient l'escalier,
Alex,
alors nous avons appelé Donna et lui avons mis son nom,
puis nous avons juste fait nos bagages.  ils
étaient juste des animaux et beaucoup pourraient y être mis et
qui seraient suffisamment sûrs pour y être mis,
donc je me souviens d'avoir fermé la porte et d'
avoir pensé d'accord ensuite et la voilà et
j'ai aidé quelques personnes supplémentaires et puis il y a eu
ce son où tout le monde
a entendu ça  premier son tu m'aimes tu
peux l'entendre craquer et tu regardes et tout le
monde s'est en quelque sorte figé pendant une seconde
[Musique]
et je commence à voir
le bâtiment s'effondrer et je suis juste tu
sais que je suis stupide je suis juste je porte  lors de
la prise de vue,
je m'appelle Phil Perman, je suis un
photographe professionnel
et je me suis précipité au World Trade
Center le matin du 11 septembre
parce que tu es, c'est comme si tu étais dans
un autre monde, tu regardes dans le
viseur
et ce n'est pas pour  comme quelques secondes de
tournage dont mon cerveau commence à réaliser,
attendez une minute, ces choses se rapprochent de
plus en plus
dans mon cadre, à quel point vont-elles se rapprocher,
est-ce que ça va venir sur l'
église et
m'attraper
alors tout  d'un coup, ces pompiers
sont passés en courant et ils m'ont en quelque sorte attrapé et m'ont
dit de cours, gamin.
[Musique]
volatilité
étrangère
je m'appelle Aristide economopolis je suis
photojournaliste
et au 911
j'étais de l'autre côté de la tour nord et elle est tombée
à l'intersection de l'église et
des rues diurnes je
lève les yeux et je vois juste le sommet qui
commence à se briser,
juste
exploser
et
je viens de me retourner et j'ai juste commencé à courir
aussi vite que je pouvais
euh
et juste de l'adrénaline pure qui me pompait
juste en sprintant et avec ça je
cours et je vois à
une petite distance un photographe que je
suis à côté de lui
et
ce photographe Joe Tabac et  Je
plonge près de
ce bus
et
la tour tombe et
prend beaucoup de débris et ce bus nous a
sauvé la vie
[Musique]
hé
magasin
[Rires]
je m'appelle Kayla Bergeron,
je travaille pour l'autorité portuaire de New
York dans le New Jersey, j'étais  au 68ème
étage de la tour nord
lorsque l'avion de ligne a heurté le
bâtiment
pour être honnête le 12 septembre alors que je
vivais encore à Manhattan au
moment où
je suis monté dans un taxi et j'ai dit
minuit
et l'un des chauffeurs était du Moyen-
Orient et cette peur  ça m'a en quelque sorte dépassé
d'un point de vue personnel, comme en le comparant au 911,
tu t'es réveillé et tu pouvais sentir la
mort
tu sais que tu pouvais marcher et tu pouvais le
voir tu pouvais le
voir dans l'air tu pouvais le sentir j'ai
vraiment eu un coup dur
sur moi
quand je souffrais de syndrome de stress post-traumatique
je ne voulais pas quitter la maison
j'avais peur de vivre dans une rue très fréquentée
donc je sursautais quand je sentais
quelque chose que je
cachais dans le placard
de mon appartement
je  je ne pouvais pas marcher comme le premier, je dirais que
50 jours, mes jambes étaient comme enfermées,
je surveillais mes arrières, j'étais à l'
affût, je m'assure juste d'essayer d'
assurer la sécurité des gens lorsque je suis au travail, tu
sais si ça  C'est comme ça que je suis le pompier, euh, l'
adjoint des pompiers, peu importe comment vous voulez m'appeler
à mon étage et je dois juste m'assurer de
faire sortir tout le monde parce que je ne
laisse personne derrière après ce que j'ai vécu,
j'ai perdu beaucoup de gens.  m'a amené à
un état dans mon esprit émotionnel où j'avais
quelque chose appelé la culpabilité du survivant. J'avais
l'impression qu'il y avait des gars au travail qui
avaient 30 ans d'expérience et qui avaient
beaucoup plus à offrir que ce petit péon
de deux ans et demi.
j'approchais de trois ans de travail,
alors quand ils ont perdu la vie, j'ai pensé que
c'était injuste pour moi, j'ai senti que le blâme était en
quelque sorte moi qui disais que je ne savais pas pourquoi j'avais dû
être épargné dans cette situation particulière,
donc au fil du temps, j'ai été témoin des horreurs
voir les familles
et souffrir voir leurs yeux
me regarder entrer
dans ma tête en disant
pourquoi est-il vivant et mon mari est mort
pourquoi est-il vivant et vous savez et mon fils
est mort euh c'est devenu douloureux et
en fait j'ai commencé à avoir un petit peu
plus loin d'eux parce que la douleur
d'essayer d'expliquer à chacun d'eux je
ressens la même douleur que toi
parce que je suis en vie tu sais
et et je ne pouvais pas lui donner de réponse
la vérité est que je ne sais pas
ouais pour moi, c'était euh
des bruits forts dont nous avons parlé, euh,
des jets au-dessus de moi, je veux dire, si je voyais un avion, je
le regarderais tout le temps jusqu'à ce que je
voie où il allait, je ne voulais pas ne pas
savoir où il allait, non  au
moment où je ne voulais pas savoir où ça
n'allait pas, euh
et puis les camions de pompiers, je veux dire, si j'entendais
un camion de pompiers faire retentir une sirène, je me
figerais littéralement, je m'arrêterais juste
parce que c'était tout autour de nous, il y a eu des
moments  euh,
je me souviens de ce qui s'est passé récemment, j'étais en
fait sous la douche, ma copine
était chez moi
et je ne sais pas, j'ai
juste commencé à m'effondrer, je ne
sais pas de quoi je ne me souviens plus pourquoi c'est
arrivé à
l'improviste  ouais, à l'improviste, nous
parlions de quelque chose, peut-être que
je ne m'en souviens pas, euh,
je sais juste que tout d'un coup, j'étais en
désordre,
je ne sais pas ce que quelque chose a déclenché
et ce n'était pas comme si elle avait fait quoi que ce soit.
nous parlions de quelque chose, peut-être d'un
voyage à New York, nous en avons parlé
plusieurs fois, j'allais voir ma famille
retourner à New York, il y avait quelque chose
et je ne pensais pas que ça m'atteindrait
comme ça,
j'étais comme ça pendant très longtemps  je veux
dire, je suis encore un petit, je veux dire,
parfois je verrouille mes portes probablement alors que
je ne devrais pas, je suis un peu paranoïaque,
mais tu sais, je vais à la douche, j'ai
mes armes juste devant la douche,
je veux dire, pas tout le temps.  il y a juste
certains jours, c'est vrai, ça reprend, tu
sais, ça s'amplifie, tu sais
[Musique]
j'ai eu un traumatisme quand j'étais enfant, j'ai été maltraité
mais j'ai en quelque sorte mis ça dans la boîte, c'était
quelque chose dont il ne fallait pas parler
alors quand le 911  c'est arrivé qui est
apparu avec les
attaques terroristes qui sont complexes et la
réponse de combat ou de fuite c'est le
type de mode
dans lequel j'étais mais oui toutes ces années j'étais
occupé,
je ne pense pas que c'était intentionnel
même si c'était une distraction  j'ai des
amis on nous a
tous demandé
pourquoi n'aviez-vous pas obtenu de l'aide plus tôt nous avons dit que ce
n'était pas le moment nous étions occupés
réfugiés
j'ai commencé à appeler les pompiers
euh pour leur demander
euh si tu allais m'amener pour de la lumière
devoir, pourquoi ne pas me considérer comme un devoir à part entière
parce que je sens que je serai capable
de le faire et ils m'ont juste repoussé
pendant environ un an. En fait, j'ai parlé au
Dr Kerry Kelly, c'est elle qui
était réellement sur le site.  ça m'a aidé à
me sauver alors je suis allé la voir et elle m'a dit,
donnons-lui un an
euh et j'ai dit d'accord
donc j'avais vraiment bon espoir
mais à la fin de ça, comme le devoir, je
le demandais et ils ont dit non, tu ne
continueras jamais  plein devoir ouais et c'était le
Dr Kelly dit qu'elle m'a dit cela et
elle a dit qu'il y avait une raison pour laquelle il y avait
un autre gars
qui avait été gravement blessé
avant le 11 septembre.
et elle s'est retrouvée avec un conflit pour qu'elle prenne
la décision de décider si elle devait  laissez-le ou
non et elle a choisi de le laisser et puis
il est mort le 11 septembre. et donc elle a dit que
depuis, c'était vraiment difficile pour moi de
décider de faire revenir quelqu'un après
ça
[Musique]
j'aime vraiment ce travail donc  ça m'a fait mal, on
m'a donné le choix de rester en
service léger, ce qui était sympa
et euh, mais puis quelqu'un est arrivé
et m'a dit mais tu peux aussi, tu peux prendre ta retraite
maintenant
et je ne voulais pas partir, c'est mon
frère Brian qui m'a convaincu  je dois
partir ouais
[Musique]
il a fallu 17 ans pour obtenir un diagnostic,
je veux dire, je savais que quelque chose n'allait pas, je
pensais que peut-être parce que j'avais été
déplacé à cause de mon travail, mais j'ai eu du
mal à m'asseoir sur une chaise et
à conduire la voiture pendant  pendant de longues périodes,
mon esprit courait à une telle vitesse
que c'était difficile à gérer et ce que
j'ai appris, c'est que l'
alcool alimente le syndrome de stress post-traumatique et le syndrome de stress post-traumatique
alimente
l'alcool. J'ai frappé l'alcool fort
comme si j'avais la peau jaune et j'étais
environ 60 livres de plus
et les gens m'appelaient l'homme jaune
et je ne savais pas pourquoi ils m'appelaient l'
homme jaune et apparemment c'était à cause
de l'alcool, combien d'années es-tu
descendu aussi profondément
oh très bien
ouais je buvais en
buvant près de  bouteille de Jack Daniels
la nuit
et puis j'étais comme de la merde tu as un
problème
tu sais c'est pour ça que
tu as
bien arrêté, c'était l'un d'entre eux et puis je
suis allé chez un médecin et ils m'ont
dit ouais tu n'es pas censé être
jaune c'est  ce n'est pas bon signe
[Musique]
cet homme
je m'appelle Srinath
j'étais ingénieur en structure pour l'
autorité portuaire de New York et du New Jersey
et j'étais au 74ème étage de la
tour nord du World Trade Center lorsque l'avion
a heurté
le sommet  à la maison
habitat jacksonville et floride
cliché
futur président médias
cette photo a
fait le tour du monde et
ils continuent d'imprimer cette photo encore et
encore
joe kelly est décédé
george je le suis, je ne suis pas en contact avec lui
ouais tu ressembles à un mort-vivant  si je l'ai
raté,
oui, alors je suppose que vous savez, pour
un journaliste, c'est peut-être ce qui me vient à
l'esprit
même si je n'avais pas l'impression d'être mort
à ce moment-là, vous savez, quelqu'un qui le
regarde pourrait
penser oh mon Dieu, je veux dire, ces gens
sortent  comme un cimetière ou
quelque chose comme ça,
tu pourrais ouais, je veux dire, je peux comprendre
comment quelqu'un pourrait penser comme ça
ouais, je
pense que ce qui ressort aussi, c'est qu'il a l'air
décontracté, je veux dire ouais ouais alors où
il est ouais c'est le cas
et ouais tard comme rien  c'est
arrivé ouais c'est vrai ouais donc si
quelque chose m'arrivait je ne penserais pas
à prendre mon sac à main ou mon étui
ouais ouais ouais donc je veux dire ce que tu ne
sais pas c'est ce qu'il y a dans mes poches j'avais
une paire de jumelles j'avais une  une
lampe de poche
et j'avais
des serviettes en papier mouillées,
tu sais, des trucs comme ça,
tu étais préparé
du mieux que je pouvais parce que je ne
savais pas, je veux dire,
surtout parce qu'après 1993,
tu sais, il y avait de la fumée et tout ça,
et puis les lumières se sont éteintes et ainsi
c'est pour ça que j'avais la lampe de poche,
je n'ai pas visité le site jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient
vidé les lieux,
si longtemps
que cela aurait pris plusieurs mois, je
n'y suis pas allé,
pourquoi
je n'avais tout simplement pas l'impression que tu sais, je veux dire,
je pouvais juste  Je ne me suis pas forcé à aller là où
tu sais que tous ces gens ont été enterrés
là-bas
ouais,
je ne peux pas vraiment expliquer
précisément ce que c'était mais tu sais, je
ne pouvais tout simplement pas
me forcer à le faire, c'est compréhensible ouais
ouais ouais
[Musique]
la photographie est
en septembre
phil  penman
louis vuitton new york
et puis tu sais je suis tombé sur Joe et notre
musique
a commencé à prendre des photos
c'était John Paul Devito
[Musique]
mais juste un spectacle très surréaliste tu sais
voir ce type avec le costume et
puis tu as John Paul ensuite  avec lui
comme ça
alors j'ai fait quelques photos
et puis tu sais, une fois que la
fenêtre était,
nous pouvions voir une sorte de vie c'est
vers quoi je suis sorti
c'est Joanne à gauche et son
amie
[Musique]
il vraiment, comment puis-je  dis
qu'il nous a eu au moment où
il nous a eu à ce moment-là
où j'avais si peur
que tu as vu à quel point nous avions peur
et c'est comme ça que nous étions tout le
temps alors quand tu me demandes comment tu te sens
aujourd'hui,
je suis venu un
J'ai longtemps regardé cette photo et j'avais l'impression
que c'était le pire moment de ma vie mais
tu sais
quelle était la meilleure photo et
il m'a donné l'
impression que je devais rencontrer cet homme.
J'étais tellement nerveuse de rencontrer Phil.
J'étais tellement nerveux
et mon patron, Mark Bailey, est venu
dans la salle de conférence avec moi
pour rencontrer Phil
et j'étais tellement nerveux que je ne savais même pas
quoi lui dire. J'étais comme bonjour
et à ce moment-là, nous sommes devenus
vraiment  bons amis
une copropriété de téléportation
[Musique]
on m'a donné la fermeture c'était la première
étape de mon rétablissement et je parle toujours
de mon rétablissement parce que ce n'était pas facile les
téléphones portables sont tombés en panne tout de suite
les pages fonctionnent toujours maintenant ce téléavertisseur
qui est bizarre
la société qui nous a fourni ces pages était
dans les tours commerciales c'est là que
nous avons obtenu nos téléavertisseurs à l'école
c'était dans les poches de la veste
et dans mes chaussures
c'est ce que vous voyez qui est
partout sur les visages de tout le monde et partout sur la
veste et tout  sur moi et tout le monde
fait la fête,
vous savez, si vous regardez certains des
points les plus sombres, ce sera le
mien ou celui de Donna ou celui de quelqu'un,
définitivement, certainement,
définitivement, un sentiment étrange, je veux
dire, je ne l'ai pas fait depuis 20 ans
septembre
[Musique]
Colorado
[  Musique]
Virginie
Californie
tout d'un coup
ouais je veux dire beaucoup d'entre eux oui à
cette époque je ne savais même pas que
c'était international parce que je n'avais encore
rien entendu de mes cousins ​​en
Italie alors quand j'ai commencé à entendre
parler de comment  gros c'était, je veux dire, c'était juste
vraiment, c'était
vraiment bizarre et difficile à
gérer,
bien sûr, quand je l'ai vu pour la première fois, j'étais comme
tu sais, quand je suis arrivé pour la première fois, j'étais comme ça,
je veux dire, j'ai ressenti un sentiment de genre
ça m'a époustouflé tu sais ma photo ma photo
tous ces gens il y a des gens qui
transportaient des gens partout
je ne sais pas ce qui l'a frappée pour avoir ma
photo tu sais il a fallu un certain temps pour
accepter ça un peu tu sais mais
une fois que je  je l'ai fait et j'ai réalisé, ok, je suis content que
ces photos aient été retirées, pas
nécessairement les miennes
mais toutes ces autres photos parce que c'est
encore une fois pour les générations futures,
je ne suis pas différent de tous les flics de la police de New York,
le fermier là-dedans, les vrais
héros n'ont pas fait  c'est sorti de là
qui est sorti et a abandonné sa vie
et
ne m'a pas fait comprendre que c'étaient les
vrais héros,
voici comment les autres vous appellent mais
pas comment vous vous appelez
John était mon ami, il était notre ami
mes copains ça  nous nous sommes réunis pour aider
et quand vous avez un ami ou une famille
où que ce soit, vous ne les abandonnez pas et
vous savez que je ne pouvais pas
faire ça,
ce temps était de notre côté, le
destin ou Dieu ou quoi que ce soit nous a permis de
sortir et 15 minutes plus tard  notre tour est
tombée, je n'ai aucune idée de pourquoi c'est arrivé
et pourquoi je suis toujours là 20 ans plus tard pour en
parler
[Musique]
j'ai souffert d'un
syndrome de stress post-traumatique par la suite,
heureusement, mon entreprise a proposé à la fois des
conseils individuels et des
conseils de groupe et  je l'ai accepté
[Musique]
nous avions l'habitude de faire ces
efforts volontaires appelés commémoration
par renouvellement chaque année du 11 septembre
et on
a proposé à l'un d'eux de rejoindre le
musée hommage et
quand je me suis inscrit et j'ai suivi leur
programme de formation et
j'ai réalisé
ce que je ferais  en termes de visite
guidée et de guidage de galerie, c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui m'a marqué,
donc j'étais heureux de faire en sorte que
chacun ait une histoire différente, mais
nous la racontons de personne à personne et c'est
ce que nous aimons faire parce que
vous savez que
vous pouvez voir des photos et vous  Je pouvais voir
des objets
mais c'est différent quand vous
parlez à quelqu'un,
la fumée importante s'est dissipée mais ensuite le
tas
contenait tout le carburéacteur et brûlait
et je ne sais pas si vous vous en souvenez
mais
ce tas a brûlé pendant six mois
et
je me souviens du  l'odeur, souviens-toi de l'odeur
ouais la semaine après que
le vent s'est tourné
vers les nœuds ces
amiante ces câbles ouais imaginez les
gens qui sont entrés dans cette pile et certains
d'entre eux avaient des masques certains avaient de meilleurs masques certains ont
enlevé le masque parce que c'était
gênant parce que le chef de l'epa  aux
États-Unis, on a dit que c'était une
chose totalement mauvaise et erronée à faire, mais
et maintenant beaucoup d'entre eux souffrent,
je repars tout le temps en guérissant et
reconnaissant d'être
venu rendre hommage ce jour-là et cela fait
partie de ma guérison continue de
ma famille.  m'a beaucoup soutenu, j'avais
de très bons amis qui étaient très
proches et
qui, vraiment, je veux dire, nous ont
rapprochés, évidemment euh,
mon collègue John, nous étions proches mais ça
a été, c'est un lien, c'est contre un
lien lui et j'ai ce lien maintenant
que quoi qu'il arrive, je ne l'ai pas
vu depuis probablement
je ne sais pas combien d'années il est
ici une fois que je suis revenu, tu
sais, avec la vie telle qu'elle est, il est à New York,
je suis en Floride, nous  on parle beaucoup on s'envoie beaucoup de textos
euh généralement des trucs drôles pour venir se faire
rire ou se taquiner tu sais
et comme même avec Donna tu
sais Donna Sparrow
je ne l'ai pas vue depuis des années
on s'envoie des textos de temps en temps on se parle de temps en temps
depuis un moment,
cette maison dans laquelle tu es, je me concentre beaucoup
dessus et cela m'a aidé à y faire face
parce que si vous avez une chose qui
cause beaucoup de stress, la meilleure chose à faire est d'
avoir beaucoup de stress, c'est d'essayer de construire une
maison.
[Musique]
je n'avais pas d'enfants, euh construire une
maison en faisait partie, donc c'est ce que j'ai
décidé de faire et cela a fonctionné pour moi
parce que vous vous concentrerez sur les
opérations quotidiennes. J'ai choisi de le faire parce que
cela m'a permis de faire ça.  C'était un endroit, c'est un refuge
mais je voulais être de cette certaine manière
et c'était quelque chose que je pouvais choisir
plutôt que d'aimer un département disant
que vous ne pouvez pas suivre cette avenue.
Recevez-vous des thérapeutes psy
pas de psy pas de thérapeute le vélo était mon
évasion je  Je me suis mis au cyclisme, j'ai une
nature très addictive, donc si vous êtes
accro à l'alcool et que mon
évasion était que je suis devenu accro au
cyclisme et
euh, c'était mon évasion,
j'irais partout dans le monde en
volant tout  ces montagnes et
tout sur le vélo et je
suis devenu vraiment accro à ça et puis
ça devient autre chose et c'est juste
un moyen pour le cerveau de
s'éloigner de tout le reste
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
il a traversé un traumatisme
je pense  il peut le sentir avec moi et il est
si doux
et j'ai fini par lui faire confiance quand je l'ai
vu pour la première fois, tu sais que sa taille
est un peu écrasante et
intimidante,
mais apprendre à le connaître, c'est un petit
sac d'amour, c'est vrai,
ça aide à créer des liens.  tout d'abord, ça
les détend
et euh après,
j'ai passé un peu de temps avec eux
car ça me profite comme ça, c'est
très thérapeutique, une grande partie de l'
énergie se
dissipe en quelque sorte dans l'air, n'est-ce pas mon
grand, tu peux te voir docteur oh
ouais mec  c'est comme aller dans un salon de
massage complet du corps
quand je reçois des gens qui viennent pour une thérapie,
ce que je leur dis, c'est que tu vois un
thérapeute, c'est ma toute première chose oui, j'étais
comme d'accord, alors ne t'arrête pas, je ne
leur demande rien
sur
ce qui se passe  continue, comment s'est passée ta semaine, tu
sais, dis-moi ce que tu ressens, je ne
fais rien de tout cela, il n'y a aucune raison pour que
le cheval le fasse à peu près pour moi
et généralement, à la fin d'une séance de thérapie,
ils parleront  pour moi et c'est comme ça que
ça devrait être
pour les gens à l'extérieur, ils ne voient peut-être pas les
avantages qu'ils sont, oh tu ne fais que
frotter le cheval
mais il y a quelque chose de magique là-dedans et ils
ont un sixième sens
mais j'ai vu Kayla au fil du temps  ces dernières
années,
elle a fait beaucoup de progrès quant à sa
direction et à ce qu'elle prévoit pour sa
vie et pour aller de l'avant.
Je pense juste qu'il faut un courage incroyable
pour passer à autre chose,
elle m'a dit : eh bien, ça va prendre 20
ans, ça pourrait aussi bien  C'était il
y a deux jours, c'est toujours aussi dramatique et
horrible que jamais,
mais maintenant vous apprenez à vivre
avec ça, je suppose que
j'étais au sommet de ma carrière,
le travail que j'adorais
et donc
j'ai un peu les larmes aux yeux.  J'y pense
parce que
j'étais au sommet
et puis je suis tombé
et
tu sais que les terroristes me l'ont pris
et pas seulement moi
et donc euh
j'aurais aimé retrouver cette vie et franchement si j'avais su, je traverserais tout
si c'était comme un bus, j'aurais donné
mon siège à quelqu'un d'autre parce que euh ce n'est pas le cas,
je ne suis pas la personne que j'avais l'intention d'être
mais euh ouais, je suis juste un peu
déçu moi-même, j'y
travaille toujours, c'est  pourquoi j'ai besoin d'une thérapie
pour la vie mais ouais, je suis en colère, je suis en colère
parce que ma vie a été prise
et je ne peux pas la récupérer,
ma
musique étrangère,
je me sentais si bien à ce moment-là,
tu sais, j'étais
vraiment en mauvais état  j'étais comme aller
les tuer tous tu sais j'étais fou dans ma tête
mais ça disparaît avec le temps tu sais le
temps fait bonjour les blessures je
ne veux voir personne blessé mais à
ce moment-là bien sûr au début
tu sais  va les tuer tous, j'étais
comme celui qui l'a
bien fait, en fait, celui qui l'a fait physiquement, la
plupart d'entre eux sont morts, celui qui est
parti ouais, trouvons-les et élevons-les, pendons-les,
attachons-les,
devons-nous le faire si vous savez qu'ils l'
ont fait  Vous avez la preuve
que oui, bien sûr, à ce moment-là, ils disaient
que tous les Saoudiens qui étaient ici, dans la
brousse, leur permettaient de retourner en
Arabie Saoudite et que tous les gens qui
aidaient ces pirates de l'air, ils étaient tous
autorisés à rentrer,
c'était vrai.  jamais, ils n'ont jamais été
poursuivis ou
arrêtés ou quoi que ce soit, ils
savent tous qu'ils étaient autorisés à revenir en arrière,
les journalistes ont été
filtrés,
alors maintenant j'étais en conflit, en fait, il y avait
quelque chose qui s'appelait, certaines
pages avaient été expurgées dans la
commission 911
et il y avait environ 19 pages qui  ont été
expurgés, je crois qu'ils ont dit
qu'ils
parlaient du soda, de la façon dont l'Arabie Saoudite
y était impliquée et qu'ils n'en voulaient pas
parce qu'ils ne voulaient pas provoquer un
conflit avec l'Arabie Saoudite parce que nous
avons beaucoup de choses avec eux avec, je suppose, le
pétrole.  c'est la croyance commune,
euh, et je me souviens avoir dit que ce n'était pas
satisfaisant pour moi, ouais, il y
a eu des discussions selon lesquelles ils auraient
trouvé l'endroit où
ils localisaient l'auteur de cela
et son nom est Ben Laden et oui, les
preuves ont montré qu'il était
le  Le cerveau de tout ça, la brousse
et l'administration étaient là pour l'avoir
et nous pensions en Afghanistan, donc je
pensais que ça allait être
une poursuite
euh et ils allaient se concentrer sur
lui,
c'était à un moment donné quand j'ai commencé à
avoir  certains doutent que c'était lorsque la
transition s'est déroulée dans notre pays, l'
Irak,
je pense que j'ai senti qu'il
y avait une réaction excessive
et je pense que c'est exactement ce que
voulaient Oussama et les terroristes et
puis il y avait des gens
qui,
vous le savez, ont trouvé cela
comme un moyen de  vous savez,
faire avancer certains de leurs propres objectifs
comme
aller répandre la démocratie au
Moyen-Orient ou quoi que ce soit, vous savez, les
politiciens essayaient de
s'enrouler
autour du drapeau américain et vous
savez, cela ressemble à des patriotes
pour leur public
avril administration afghanistan
[Musique]
moins d'un  une cuillère à café pleine d'anthrax sec
dans une enveloppe a fermé le
Sénat des États-Unis à l'automne 2001,
ce qui a forcé plusieurs centaines de personnes à
subir un traitement médical d'urgence et
a tué deux postiers.
J'ai toujours été sceptique quant à la politique,
donc cela a probablement renforcé mon
scepticisme et
mon quoi.  est-ce que vous appelez du cynisme
à propos de l'ensemble du système
[Musique],
je me souviens avoir pensé que la France
n'était pas impliquée, pensant bien
que c'est leur point, c'est leur choix,
ils n'ont pas à être impliqués, je veux dire,
euh
[Musique] la Seconde
Guerre mondiale, c'est un peu  différent
parce que sur leur front intérieur,
ils sont impliqués, qu'ils le veuillent
ou non, nous
étions là, nous avons aidé quoi que ce soit, ce
n'était pas leur front intérieur, ils l'ont
battue à l'ONU, souvenez-vous de cette
partie, je ne me souviens pas exactement de cette
partie, non, alors  et après ce refus,
il y a eu beaucoup de French bashing aux
États-Unis, rappelez-vous que oui, ouais, quelqu'un
disait plus de frites
chez McDonald's,
alors maintenant, c'était certains des
politiciens, vous savez, qui disaient oh,
vous savez, pas de frites,
donc je veux dire  c'est comme ça que ces choses
peuvent devenir stupides, vous le savez,
ils n'ont pas
envahi la France,
mes concitoyens,
à cette heure-ci, les
forces américaines et de la coalition en sont aux
premiers stades d'opérations militaires visant à
désarmer l'Irak, à libérer son peuple
et à défendre le monde contre un grave
danger.
mes ordres, les forces de la coalition ont commencé à
frapper des cibles sélectionnées d'importance militaire
pour saper la capacité de Saddam Hussein à
faire la guerre,
vous savez, les fabricants d'armes et tous les
autres s'accrochent aux patriotes et
vous savez, les porte-
drapeaux, tous ces gens dont vous savez qu'ils
veulent se battre,
donc je pense  n'importe quelle excuse est assez bonne pour
eux, donc aller en Irak n'était pas la bonne
solution,
je ne pense pas, donc je ne pense pas, donc
rien à voir avec le fait d'observer qu'ils ont
tout fabriqué,
ces armes de destruction massive
qui sont une tache sur notre nation et  ça va
être comme ça pour toujours je ne
sais pas ce qui se passait dans la tête de
nos dirigeants je ne sais pas si c'était une
vengeance pour les bush boys ou pas
euh
mais tu dois remettre en question leur jugement
on nous a nourri de désinformation
vous  je sais que la désinformation, qu'elle provienne d'un
gouvernement
ou de médias de n'importe où, peut être
extrêmement dangereuse, je pense que la perspective
rend beaucoup plus facile la remise en question,
mais
chaque fois que je pense que vous utilisez l'armée, je
pense que vous devriez toujours remettre en question ces
décisions dès le début,
si nous  sortir dans un autre pays du tiers monde,
c'est
censé être tertiaire par rapport à ça je
tu me dis que nous devrions ils me
disent que nous ne devrions pas
je ne sais pas
je ne suis pas dans les cercles non non ils disent que
je le suis probablement  bien sûr, il y avait du vrai des
deux côtés et du faux des deux
côtés.
[Musique]
ce soir, je peux informer le
peuple américain et le monde que
les États-Unis ont mené une
opération qui a tué Oussama ben Laden, le
chef d'Al-Qaida
et un  terroriste responsable
du meurtre de milliers d'hommes, de
femmes et d'enfants innocents
[Musique]
j'étais au lit il y a 10 ans et j'ai reçu
un appel téléphonique disant
qu'Oussama Ben Laden avait été tué
j'étais dans un sommeil profond j'ai eu peur j'ai
mis  elle va passer les nouvelles j'ai mis
les nouvelles j'étais comme oh mon dieu
quelqu'un l'a finalement eu
et puis
j'étais j'étais soulagé
j'étais soulagé pendant environ une journée
et j'ai dit oh mon dieu ils devaient venir
nous frapper à nouveau
alors  oh,
toujours au fond de ma tête, je pense que
nous allons être frappés à nouveau, ma
réaction, je savais que beaucoup de gens n'accepteraient peut-être pas,
mais euh, j'étais en fait triste, je
pensais que nous, en tant qu'américains, ferions
la bonne chose en les capturant et en
les mettant  au tribunal, d'accord,
mais euh,
est-ce que je veux le tuer pour ça, non,
je veux l'avoir en prison, je veux
enquêter, qui sait quelles autres
informations il aurait pu avoir pour capturer
davantage de personnes, qui sait, peut-être que le
peuple saoudien l'aurait fait  a été capturé
maintenant tu vois ce que je veux dire euh peut-être que Sortie
serait maintenant tenue pour responsable parce que nous
avons eu des informations à la place tu lui as tiré dessus donc
j'ai été envoyé par ça aussi je suis plus
pacifiste je ne pense pas vraiment que
la violence va vraiment  engendrer
quelque chose de plus que plus de violence dans le
futur
est-ce que ça a tout arrêté non parce qu'alors
nous avons eu l'ISIS
vous savez et
puis ça a continué toutes les décapitations et
tout donc
rien ne l'a vraiment arrêté, juste un autre
prend le relais je ne vois pas
vraiment sa mort  trop changé
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] quelques
jours après
et pendant la première année environ et les
patriotes de ce pays ont explosé, je
veux dire, il n'y
avait pas de noir blanc bleu vert jaune
il n'y avait pas de méchant  les bons
flics s'entendaient bien à l'arrière, je
veux dire, tout le monde était comme si nous étions notre
seul corps, soyons un seul corps, je me dis que si
nous avions pu le garder,
c'était un sentiment tellement génial d'être dans un
pays où tout le monde vient de se retrouver  ça
n'avait pas d'importance, ça n'avait vraiment pas d'importance, je
veux dire,
je suis content d'avoir vécu ça parce que
beaucoup de gens ne l'ont pas fait, mes
enfants ne savent pas que
mes parents en ont vraiment
vu un peu, vous savez, mais
les gens qui  Je suis mort juste avant, je n'ai jamais
su que ce pays avait eu un peu de
paix pendant un certain temps, au moins à New York,
je veux dire, je ne vivais pas partout mais
je veux dire à New York, qui est très,
vous savez, le creuset
était très cohérent.  je
pensais de cette façon de toute façon quand vous regardez
la situation dans son ensemble en ce moment,
euh et même avec les élections
en ce moment,
notre pays est tellement divisé
que
c'est du jamais vu, je veux dire, je
pense que
l'Irak,
euh, je pense que cela a quelque chose à voir avec
ça et euh
pendant que nous  Nous sommes unis, nous recommençons
comme d'habitude
et je pense qu'avec le leadership que nous avons eu
à Washington
récemment,
cela a été très source de division, nous sommes
plus divisés maintenant,
je ne vois aucune force unificatrice parce que
ni les démocrates ni les républicains ne
visent à obtenir le  les affaires des gens ne se font
plus
seulement politiquement, mais aussi
socialement, nous devenons plus polarisés
et
je pense que c'est vraiment dangereux que
nous enseignons les mathématiques et les sciences et toutes ces
autres choses à l'école,
je pense que ce serait formidable si nous enseignions
l'empathie et la compassion
lorsque nous arrêtons  voir les gens comme des
humains et simplement comme un parti politique,
une nationalité ou une religion, c'est
ainsi qu'un autre 9 11 se produit
lorsque Donald Trump était notre président,
je me sentais tellement en sécurité,
peut-être que
les gens pourraient penser à moi, qu'est-ce qu'elle
veut dire par là parce que vous savez, Donald
Trump,
j'aime  Trump et
les autres pays savaient
que s'ils nous poursuivaient,
ils avaient peur de lui parce qu'il leur suffirait d'
appuyer sur un bouton et de
les faire
exploser. Maintenant, tout ce que j'entends, c'est le terrorisme en Israël, le terrorisme, ici, nous recevons à nouveau des menaces.
encore une fois,
cela m'arrive au
revoir New York,
pensez-vous que le 911 a changé la
société américaine et comment
cela se passe encore, je veux dire, ça a changé,
je veux dire que le
World Trade Center qui descend,
cette image
est
quelque chose qui est en
quelque sorte gravé dans les gens  vous savez,
donc d'une manière ou d'une autre, il y a une certaine
fascination à ce sujet, je veux dire, même maintenant,
cela fait 20 ans et nous en parlons à
propos du 11 septembre. donc il doit y avoir
quelque chose de
bien,
peut-être parce que cela a
promu tant d'autres choses comme pourquoi l'
Amérique est-elle toujours là  Afghanistan, après 20
ans, c'est à cause du 11 septembre. Pourquoi y a-t-il un
désordre en Iraq,
c'est le 11 septembre, c'est vrai, et en
Syrie, cela a probablement
quelque chose à voir avec le 11 septembre. La Libye a quelque chose à voir
avec le 11 septembre. Vous associez tous ces événements au
11 septembre.  je pense que oui, je pense que tu dois le faire
parce que c'est ce qui a lancé cette
affaire,
donc j'espère que le FBI ne me poursuivra pas
pour quoi que ce soit,
pour la CIA ou quoi que ce soit [
Rires] [Musique
]
la résilience
[Musique]
euh
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
toi